Fest steht, dass es im Weltraum deutlich mehr
Materie gibt als Antimaterie.
Doch das Rätselraten ist groß: Warum in
aller Welt existiert dieses Ungleichgewicht;
wie lässt sich die Dominanz der Materie im
Universum erklären?!
Am Genfer Kernforschungszentrum CERN ist man
genau dieser Frage auf der Spur und hat jetzt
mit Hilfe einer super aufwändigen Analyse
von Teilchenzerfällen eine Lösung parat.
Konnten die Experten das mysteriöse Rätsel
um die Antimaterie jetzt also endlich lüften?!
Alle wichtigen Infos dazu bekommt ihr jetzt
bei Clixoom Science & Fiction - abonniert
den Kanal, denn hier gibt es täglich spannende
Science-Videos - herzlich willkommen!
Schon seit knapp 90 Jahren wissen wir, dass
jedes Teilchen einen Partner hat - ein Anti-Teilchen
quasi.
Beim Elektron ist es zum Beispiel das Positron.
Doch wenn wir weit zurückschauen, wird nicht
nur deutlich, wie wenig wir bis heute über
Materie und Antimaterie wissen, sondern auch
wie wichtig das Zusammenspiel von Materie
und Antimaterie ist.
Denn beim Urknall vor 13,8 Milliarden Jahren
entstand heutiger Vorstellung zufolge genau
so viel Antimaterie wie die uns bekannte Materie.
Alle diese Teilchen im jungen Kosmos prallten
auf entgegengesetzt gepolte Anti-Teilchen.
Doch warum haben sich Antimaterie und Materie
nicht sofort wieder vollständig vernichtet?
So wie es doch eigentlich immer der Fall ist,
wenn Anti-Teilchen und Teilchen aufeinandertreffen?!
Die Antwort darauf wissen wir bis heute nicht.
Doch klar ist: Das ganze war wohl eine Art
kosmische Fügung, denn aus dem übrig gebliebenen
Bruchteil bildeten sich Lauf von Milliarden
Jahren Sterne, Planeten und Galaxien.
Astronomie-Teams weltweit gehen davon aus,
dass ein subtiler Unterschied zwischen Materie
und Antimaterie dafür gesorgt hat, dass ein
Teil der Materie überlebt hat.
Doch worin genau liegt dieser Unterschied?
Warum gibt es dieses Ungleichgewicht im Universum?
Warum bestehen Sterne, Planeten und Menschen
fast ausschließlich aus Materie und warum
ist die Antimaterie dagegen solch ein Exot?
Welche subatomaren Prozesse im Urknall haben
etwas mehr Materie als Antimaterie hervorgebracht?
Fragen über Fragen, auf die wir bis heute
keine endgültigen Antworten wissen.
Experten und Expertinnen vermuten, dass ein
gewisser Effekt, der etwas mit der Symmetrie
zu tun, also das Gleichgewicht oder eben Nicht-Gleichgewicht
von Materie und Antimaterie, die Antwort auf
diese Frage sein könnte.
Ein Mechanismus der Symmetrieverletzung, der
alle Elementarteilen betrifft, die aus einem
Quark und einem Antiquark bestehen.
Schon seit längerer Zeit wird also vermutet:
Naturgesetze behandeln Materie und Antimaterie
nicht gleichwertig.
Schon vor längerer Zeit wurde bei den sogenannten
K- und B-Mesonen ein Unterschied festgestellt.
Mesonen bestehen aus insgesamt sechs Quarksorten
und sind ab und an auch aus Antiquarks aufgebaut.
Experimente in den 60er-Jahren hatten gezeigt,
dass der Zerfall von K-Mesonen aus Antiquarks
nicht exakt symmetrisch zum Zerfall der Materie-Variante
der K-Mesonen abläuft.
Heißt also vereinfacht: Physikalische Prozesse
ändern sich, wenn die Ladung (C) vertauscht
wird und Teilchen durch ihre Antiteilchen
ersetzt werden.
Zudem ändern sich die physikalischen Prozesse,
wenn sie spiegelverkehrt (Parität P) betrachtet
werden.
Das heißt es gibt ebenso eine Veränderung
bei der Änderung des Spins, der Drehrichtung
von Elementarteilchen.
Das Phänomen, bei dem die sogenannte “CP-Symmetrie
verletzt wird, wird in der Fachsprache auch
als “CP-Verletzung” bezeichnet: Das C
steht dabei wie gesagt für “Charge”,
also Ladung und das P für “parity”, also
“Parität”.
In der Physik heißt das so viel wie die Symmetrieeigenschaft
eines Systems gegenüber seiner räumlichen
Spiegelung.
Dass übrigens auch die B-Mesonen die CP-Symmetrie
verletzen, ist seit Anfang der 2000er Jahre
bekannt.
Der Zerfall dieser B-Mesonen im Experiment
lieferte ebenso wie der Zerfall der K-Mesonen
einen Überschuss an Materie.
Doch beide waren viel zu klein, um die Dominanz
der Materie im Universum zu erklären.
Jetzt ist es einem Physik-Team vom Genfer
Kernforschungszentrum CERN gelungen, einen
weiteres Puzzlestück in diesem Zusammenhang
aufzudecken.
Konkret hatten die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler die Zerfälle sogenannter
D0-Mesonen im Auge.
Diese Teilchen bestehen aus einem Charm- und
einem Anti-Up-Quark und wurden vor 40 Jahren
aufgespürt.
Im Large Hadron Collider hatte man die D0-Mesonen
und ihre Gegenstücke in den vergangenen Jahren
in großer Menge produziert.
Doch die Teilchen sind äußerst kurzlebig
und zerfielen schnell wieder in andere Partikel.
So entstand in den Jahren zwischen 2011 und
2018 ein riesiger Datenberg.
Um an ein Ergebnis zu kommen, mussten die
LHC-Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
die entstandenen Produkte zählen.
Dabei kam heraus, dass die Anti-D-Mesonen
schneller zerfallen als ihre Materie-Pendants,
die wohl deutlich stabiler sind.
Heißt also im Klartext: Auch hier verletzten
die Zerfälle der ungeladenen D0-Mesonen die
Symmetrie-Regel.
Das CERN-Forschungsteam schlussfolgert aus
diesem Ergebnis, dass solche symmetrie-verletzenden
Prozesse eben auch im frühen Universum eine
Schlüsselrolle gespielt haben.
Dies könnte dann auch dafür gesorgt haben,
dass eben nicht die ganze Materie vernichtet
wurde.
Das Ergebnis vom CERN kann zusammen mit den
bereits bekannten Unterschieden tatsächlich
einen Teil der Materie-Dominanz im Universum
erklären.
Doch auch der nun gemessene Effekt ist längst
nicht ausreichend, um das komplette Übergewicht
zu verstehen.
Dafür ist immer noch eine deutlich größere
Verletzung der CP-Symmetrie notwendig, als
man in Experimenten bislang beobachten konnte.
Was aber wirklich frappierend ist, dass hier
in immer mehr Fällen diese Ungleichheit zwischen
Materie und Antimaterie festgestellt.
Nun setzen die Fachleute auf die Erzeugung
von B-Mesonen in gigantisch großer Zahl.
Dies könnte durch Teilchen-Kollisionen im
Teilchenbeschleuniger “SuperKEKB” in Japan
klappen, da er gerade erst enorm aufgerüstet
wurde.
Auch in Sachen Neutrinos könnte ein entscheidender
Erfolg kurz bevorstehen.
Doch auch hier reicht die Datenlage jedoch
derzeit noch nicht aus, um weitere subatomare
Prozesse nachzuweisen, bei denen Materie überlegen
ist.
Auf eine finale Theorie zum Materie-Antimaterie-Ungleichgewicht
müssen wir wohl offensichtlich noch einige
Zeit warten.
ANTIMATERIE-Schauer in Hurrikan gefunden!
Draufklicken und staunen.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!